[Music]
what will your last 10 years look
like will you be quick enough for a game
of tag with your
grandchild strong enough to embrace
every moment
will you grow old with
Vitality or get old with
[Music]
disease it's time to decide
Dr Joel wallik was born into Farm living
in rural Missouri where he tended to
vegetable crops and livestock with equal
care as he worked on his high school
studies and on becoming an eagle scout
Dr wallet gravitated towards animal
science plant science soil science and
veterinary medicine to learn more Dr
wallik got a summer job at the St St
Louis Zoo where he had the privilege of
caring for exotic animals alongside
Marlon Perkins of Mutual of Omaha's Wild
Kingdom Fame inspired by Mr Perkins Dr
wallik found his mission early in life
to protect the welfare of animals plants
and the Earth itself he wanted all
living things to thrive and prosper back
on the Family Farm Dr wallik had an
epiphany that would Advance his new
mission for decades to come
he realized that livestock received
better nutrition than humans Dr wallik
observed that nutrient DSE Alfalfa
pellets fed to livestock were a coste
effective gold standard practice for
preventing infertility birth defects
heart disease arthritis and other
degenerative diseases but he wondered
why is it common practice for livestock
to get this nutrition but not humans as
Dr wallik went to the UN University of
Missouri to study Agriculture and
veterinary medicine he was determined to
solve this nutritional mystery in
organic chemistry class Dr wallik had
another breakthrough when he learned
that minerals are needed for hundreds of
life sustaining reactions in the body
with his agricultural background Dr
wallik also knew that these same
minerals are often lacking in the soil
and in our diet Dr wallik knew he was on
to something significant after after
receiving his Bachelor of Science in
agriculture in
1962 and his Doctorate in veterinary
medicine in
1964 he began chasing the answers that
he knew would bring vibrant health and
wellness to all living creatures on
Earth he studied nutritional deficiency
diseases he began working as a
Veterinary pathology assistant
conducting up to 25 animal autopsies
daily he investigated the mineral intake
of the world's longest living cultures
he traveled to Africa to treat and save
exotic animals and endangered species in
1966 he was invited by Marlin Perkins to
participate in a $7.5 million National
Institutes of Health study on ecology
environment pollution and plant and
animal health the massive study became
Dr Wall's Focus for the next 12 years
over time Dr wallik performed thousands
of animal autopsies across 450 4 species
including 3,000
humans his work was included in 70
peer-reviewed Journal articles and 15
textbook
chapters Dr wallik also began working on
his own textbook the diseases of exotic
animals the medical and surgical
management which is now recommended by
the Smithsonian Institute as a
foundation text for all
zoos Dr wallick's discoveries from this
prolific time are still used today to
reduce degenerative disease improve
fertility and extend longevity for
exotic animals and livestock but most
significantly after thousands of animal
and human autopsies Dr wallik gained
unprecedented Insight on the inner
workings of the Earth's inhabitants what
he discovered was a near Universal Trend
across species minerals were the
currency of life itself
soon after this Revelation Dr wallik
identified the first non-human case of
cystic fibrosis in a Reis monkey he
named selenium deficiency as the cause
challenging the established belief that
the disease was genetic in nature Dr
Wall's findings were met with resistance
as the NIH and media alike tried to
silence his Discovery and discredit his
qualifications knowing that his
discoveries could help millions of
people if he had additional
qualifications at age 40 Dr wallik
decided to become a naturopathic doctor
after receiving his ND Dr Wallock
started a practice and began adapting
his Veterinary nutritional formulas for
human use these formulations such as his
liquid mineral ttty worked so well that
his patients told everyone they knew
soon his Clinic was seeing 50 people
daily with his Clinic's capacity maxed
out out Dr wallik realized he needed a
better system that would enable him to
help more people information was the
answer by teaching others how to achieve
and share vibrant Health he could remove
all limitations and help millions of
people Dr wallet created an educational
Health seminar called Dead Doctors Don't
Lie the tape of his seminars resonated
so powerfully with Americans that it
sold over 150 million copies without the
benefit of social
media with Dead Doctors Don't Lie Dr
wallik finally had a way to go directly
to the public with his own information
on nutrition information he knew could
dramatically improve their health but Dr
Wall's next breakthrough was the real
game Cher enabling newly healthy people
to achieve amazing quality of life all
by helping others
[Music]
it all started with physical health by
supplying premium nutritional
formulations that were great tasting
easy to absorb and highly bioavailable
he could reverse nutritional
deficiencies he knew from experience
that his plant- derived colloidal
mineral supplements ments delivered
Wellness benefits that were so powerful
people could feel them across all
aspects of their lives he also had
successful supplements from his Clinic
days that would Blossom on a bigger
stage Dr wallik streamlined his 90
essential nutrients message into 90 for
life and presented his most important
supplements in a healthy body pack
youngevity now had its core Foundation
products in place as he pioneered new
youngevity supplements including
cuttingedge liquid and neutr Crystal
delivery forms he Unleashed even more
dramatic results people felt a
difference when they took them they
wanted to buy more because each new
youngevity product made them feel better
than before with youngevity supplements
results were now the rule not the
exception when people felt better
physically happiness followed their
mental emotional and social health
flourished people were empowered by
their own Wellness which in turn
inspired others they felt so healthy
taking youngevity formulas that they
shared them with everyone they
knew seeing how information transformed
health and affected positive change Dr
wallik developed a new goal to challenge
petition and at times defend the FDA to
enable qualified Health claims for
nutritional supplements in challenging
the FDA Dr wallik helped change the face
of Healthcare in America securing the
ability to deliver truthful health
information to the public among his most
significant victories was a qualified
Health claim that the mineral selenium
May reduce the risk of certain cancers
Dr gearhard schraer head of the UCSD
chemistry Department founder of the
biological Trace element journal and one
of the official nominators for
candidates for the Nobel Prize in
medicine was the lead scientific Council
for this petition working alongside Dr
Wallock to convince the FDA to allow
this claim youngevity became the first
and only direct sales company to ever
successfully petition the FDA to make
qualified Health claims this reinforced
youngevity's reputation as being a
different type of direct sales company
one where creating Health was the top
priority achieved by any means necessary
hi I'm Dr Joel wallik and what makes me
different is that I have a degree in
agriculture I'm a veterinarian I have a
post-doctoral fellowship in comparative
pathology have done over 30,000
autopsies including 454 species of zoo
animals and human beings and I'm a
primary care physician as a naturopathic
physician since
1982 and I'm here to tell you that
you're going to hear something totally
different than you've ever heard before
when it comes to dealing with all the
major degenerative diseases all the
diseases the doctors have told you are
genetically transmitted all of the birth
effects you can prevent you'll be glad
you watch this
video what we're going to talk about is
how you can protect yourself how you can
protect your family the people you love
your church mates your neighbors and
your workmates this is something we need
to do the medical system has failed us
terribly and by doing Simple Things by
taking action you'll be able to do this
do not just sit here and say man that
was very entertaining and do nothing
because then you will not be happy with
the outcome if you take action you'll be
very very happy with the
outcome well high blood pressure is a
very common disease it's certainly not
it is not genetically transmitted it's a
simple acquired disease um in most cases
it's caused by mineral
deficiency and you take the complete set
of minerals all essential nutrients with
a complete Spectrum minerals and in most
cases the blood pressure will begin to
drop and blood pressure is one of those
nice things uh as your blood pressure
drops you can monitor yourself keep a
log uh keep track of your own blood
pressure and as the blood pressure drops
you can wean yourself off your
medications on occasion if people have
what we would call kidney failure you
can also cause high blood pressure
because the kidneys will release a
hormone called renin re n i n which
drives the blood pressure up trying to
drive more blood through the uh small
block blood vessels that result in high
blood pressure so what do we do for high
blood pressure we like to give the 90
essential nutrients 160 minerals 16
vitamins 12 essential amino acids three
essential fatty acids and um in case
there's a circulation problem
contributing to this I like to throw in
the ultimate daily tablets and this will
support and promote healthy blood flow
through obstructed arteries and also
support healthy blood pressure don't
forget to give off don't forget to give
up the inflammatory foods fried foods
processed Meats uh things like Deli
slices sandwich meats sausage ham bacon
blone have to give up gluten and oils no
olive oil no coconut oil no margin
mayonnaise salad dressings cooking
oils arthritis is very common
degenerative disease it is certainly not
genetically transmitted in any way shape
or form i' say 90% of arthritis uh begin
as osteopenia osteoprosis ostearthritis
degenerate arthritis and really gets bad
when you get to the bone to bone
arthritis point there is a secondary
type of arthritis called rheumatoid
arthritis which is an infection with a
bug called micoplasma you can cure a
rheumat arthritis in two weeks with a
antibod called Minocycline kills the bug
very quickly and then you do have the
residual damage and the residual damage
of rheumat arthritis and um the other
forms of degener G of arthritis I like
to use the healthy Bone and Joint pack
all 90 essential nutrients 60 minerals
16 vitamins 12 essential amino acids
three essential fatty acids there's a
special emphasis on what we call
glucogel as part of the healthy Bone and
Joint pack and for an average adult I
like 15 a day five at breakfast lunch
and dinner and that's designed to
support and promote maintenance repair
of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue disc between the
vertebrae bone matrix and Bone itself
diabetes is a very interesting um
degenerative disease of the blood sugar
system it has nothing to do with
genetics it is not genetically
transmitted we've known for 70 years
that it's a simple mineral deficiency
disease and regardless of age a type 2
diabetes which makes up 98% of the
diabetic population I would get them on
all 90 essential nutrients 60 essential
minerals 16 vitamins 12 essential amino
acids three essential fatty acids and
throw in what we call the secret sauce
sweetties and it has the minerals that
are missing when you have uh type 2
diabetes uh you take the supplement
program one per 100 pounds per body
weight one bottle per month per 100
pounds of body weight that's three um a
day per 100 pounds of body weight and um
you take your fasting blood sugar each
morning before you medicate yourself and
as your blood sugar drops you reduce
your medication as you've been taught to
do by your doctor when your blood sugar
gets below 100 without medication for a
week in a row uh you're able to just
drop back to where where you're U taking
a fasting blood sugar once or twice a
week to kind of keep tabs on it but it
is not a genetically transmitted disease
easily
remedied obesity is not a genetically
transmitted disease and is certainly not
lack of exercise or eating too much it's
actually a simple mineral deficiency uh
you take the 90 essential nutrients 60
minerals 16 vitamins 12 essential amino
acids three essential fatty acids and
we' like to throw in an accelerator uh
we call uh ASAP one dropper full under
your tongue 30 minutes before each meal
if you need if you need to lose more
than 50 pounds I would actually have you
take a droper full on your tongue 30
minutes before each meal and a second
droper full on your tongue 15 minutes
before each meal and you'll begin to
lose up to half a pound to two lounds a
day this is a simple mineral deficiency
disease has nothing to do with exercise
has nothing to do with eating too much
eating too much as a symptom of these
mineral
deficiencies well infertility is a very
simple problem I've gotten more women
pregnant than Solomon okay it's very
simple disease this almost always
involves gluten intolerance so that the
mother cannot absorb nutrients it
requires an enormous amount of nutrients
just like going through puberty to get
pregnant and have a good pregnancy you
need to have all 90 essential nutrients
60 minerals 16 vit vins 12 essential
amino acids three essential fatty acids
and a gluten-free diet maximize
nutrition one of the things you have to
be concerned with are women who get
pregnant and then have miscarriages uh
early on and even in Middle pregnancy uh
this is not infertility because a woman
can get pregnant but they do have a
gluten intolerance and can't maintain
the pregnancy because they cannot absorb
nutrients it's imperative that all women
who have an infertility problem or have
a miscarriage problem must be on a
gluten-free diet
ADD ADHD are certainly not caused by
vaccinations you can throw in autism
into the mix here ADD ADHD and autism
are all nutritional deficiencies
sometimes of the embryo the embryo uh
can be born as a little human being with
autism and ADD and ADHD to varying
degrees including um some variations on
um fetal alcohol syndrome fetal drug
syndrome and so forth it could be
Pharmaceuticals prescription drugs as
well as street drugs and then of course
there are babies that are born perfectly
normal but then acquire ADD and ADHD and
autism because of
malnutrition um big um
uh a big thing you have to appreciate is
that our baby formulas including gerbal
infam and simac have less than 20% of
the nutrients that are necessary for a
healthy growing person and we have to
supplement these babies before they're
conceived all through the pregnancy they
developed in from the moment they're
born you cannot depend solely on
Commercial formulas or natural
foods there's a whole battery of
diseases that afflict the brain we're
talking about depression M depression
bipolar disease
schizophrenia um and these diseases are
all what a psychologist or psychiatrist
would call um they would call them
chemical imbalances they would call them
chemical imbalances and of course there
are chemical imbalances not Prozac
imbalances but vitom mineral imbalances
so the first thing I like to do for
people with these types of emotional
problems that would include anxiety
attacks and panic attacks they have to
get off of all sugar all alcohol
absolutely no fried food on process
meets no oils no margins mayonnaise Sal
dress cooking oils absolutely no gluten
no wheat bur our oats and then they must
take the 90 cents of nutrients we're
talking 16 minerals 16 botoms 12
essential amino acids three essential
fatty acids and make sure that they have
healthy protein and fats with every meal
I like them to eat eggs every
day the biggest cause of low energy and
fatigue is just lack of nutrition uh
that old aded you are what you eat is
absolutely positively not true you're
not what you eat you are what you absorb
and so when people have chronic fatigue
syndrome they have what people call
candidasis low energy just really not
with it I like them get them on a
glutenfree free diet no wheat brother IR
o no fried foods no processed Meats with
nitrates and nitrites no oils and then I
put them on the 90 cents of nutrients I
like the healthy heart and brain pack
for people with these emotional problems
throw in the de-stress capsules three of
those twice a day per 100 pounds of body
weight
and things look
Rosy Sleep Disorders are a mix of
problems um insomnia is actually due to
mineral deficiencies uh you take all 90
essential nutrients 60 minerals you take
60 minerals 16 vitamins 12 essentio
acids three essential fatty acids and
sleep comes easy you can take a ounce of
our liquid U FX plus before bedtime and
ensure a good night sleep sleep apnea is
a normal procedure look at a newborn
baby they have sleep apnea you look at a
dog sleep you look at an elephant sleep
you look at a giraffe sleep every
vertebrae has sleep apne it's an
absolutely normal um Behavior Uh IAL
system for financial purposes has turned
this into disease with cat machines and
surgeries it's absolutely criminal uh
there is no such thing as people dying
of sleep apnea or snoring the only time
you're going to die from snoring and
sleep apnea is when your sleep partner
shoots
you skin problems are always nutritional
deficiency diseases obviously there's
certain infections but 99% of the time
uh things that don't respond to Medical
approaches are nutritional deficiencies
and invariably they secondary
nutritional deficiencies meaning the
person has usually gluten intolerance
they can't have wheat barley R oats if
they do eat wheat barley R oats they get
a contact enteritis and this causes
their intestines and Flame some diares
will call it leaky gut syndrome celiac
disease appendicitis diverticulitis iral
B syndrome inflammatory bow disease
we're talking about um uh things like
cronis disease all of these are due to
gluten intolerance well at that point
you cannot absorb nutrients particularly
the omega-3 essential fatty acids which
results in Asthma as well as things like
um dermatitis eczema
psoriasis rosace on the face and your
intestines look like your skin does and
you have to get off of gluten all 90
essential nutrients you have to take the
um 60 minerals 16 vitamins 12 essential
amino acids three essential fatty acids
I would take extra of the omega-3
essential fatty acids the EFA pluses
take three of those twice a day per 100
pounds of body weight and eczema and
Asthma dermatitis and Asthma psoriasis
and asthma rosace asthma usually go away
in anywhere from 3 to four
months cancer is a self-inflicted
disease it is not genetic in any way
shape or form is self-inflicted from the
time um before you're conceived all
through the pregnancy you're developed
in from the moment you're born is caused
by a combination of free radicals and
lack of protection by lack of protection
I mean lack of bioflavonoids lack of
antioxidants to protect you from free
radical damage trans fatty acids
heterocyclic amines and acrylamides if
you want to avoid cancer you must avoid
fried foods processed Meats with
nitrates and nitrites you must give up
oils including olive oil you must give
up coconut oil you must give up
margarine mayonnaise celles cooking oil
and if eat canned fish you got to be
packed in water mustard tomato sauce not
oils no gluten no wheat brother IR oats
in addition to taking the 90 centi of
nutrients appropriate for your body
weight 60 minerals 16 vitamins 12
essential amino acids three essential
fatty acids I would like to throw in
high levels of antioxidants we have some
great ones of cell Shield
rtq um R for Resveratrol t for turer Q
for cortin then I also like the
imortalium uh this is built on the Nobel
Prize winning information of
2009 and um actually helps um maintain
the life and the health and the
stability of the telome which are the
endcaps and the chromosomes you do not
want to leave home without
it birth effects are very worrisome
totally preventable set of events U
birth effects are actually caused by
malnutrition of the embryo there's not a
single now hear me there's not a single
genetically transmitted birth effect
that's all been a big myth that was
running down the wrong Rat Hole okay and
um it's all caused by all birth effects
are caused by malnutrition of the embryo
and you can't name me a birth effect
that's caused by genetically transmitted
disease now doctors say that but it's
absolutely not true and so it's it's the
responsibility the OBG in it's a
responsibility of the grandmother the
mother uh to be long before she misses
the first two periods to take all 90
essential nutrients to protect the
embryo remember you are not what you eat
you are what you absorb so you have to
maximize absorption no gluten no wheat
barley fry and oats take the 90
essential nutrients 60 minerals 16
vitamins 12 essential amino acids three
essential fatty acids and you'll be able
to reduce the risk of birth effects
almost zero even if the whole family's
been full of them forever and that's
because when people get generationals
diseases like diabetes or CLE pellet or
down syndrome it is not genetically
transmitted it's because mother cannot
absorb nutrients because she has a
gluten intolerance or they live in a
place in which these nutrients exist in
very low
amounts Alzheimer disease is a physician
caused disease it did not exist 43 years
ago today it's the number four killer of
adults over the age of 65 it's a simple
nutritional deficiency disease uh big
study done by Johns Hopkins came out in
2004 showed that they could actually
prevent alz disease and a controlled
double blind randomized study on 5,000
people over a 10year period with a
special diet restricting certain foods
and supplementing with nutrients right
and uh in February of 2012 the FDA came
out and said uhoh give up statin drugs
because statin drugs the drugs at lower
cholesterol actually increase your risk
of Alzheimer disease and type two
diabetes do not take statin drugs that's
because when you have alimer disease
your brain loses the myin which is the
insulation material and milin is 100%
cholesterol there are four other
dementias vascular dementia corov
syndrome Mor corov syndrome and um
Alzheimer disease and Alzheimer disease
Al also there is the uh dementia that's
caused by a vitamin B12 deficiency goes
along with pernicious anemia so uh all
90 essential nutrients 160 minerals 16
vitamins 12 essential amino acids three
essential fatty acids six eggs a day per
100 pounds of body weight poached also I
would throw in the de-stress capsules uh
three of those three times a day when a
person has dementia i' take that many
just to prevent
dementia cardiovascular disease is not
genetically transmitted say certainly
it's um it's uh one of those diseases
that are self-inflicted it's caused by
free radical damage to the heart has
nothing to do with cholesterol there's
no heart disease that has anything to do
with cholesterol clogged arteries do not
due to cholesterol stroke is not due to
cholesterol cholesterol has nothing to
do with cardiovascular disease nothing
so what causes cardiovascular disease
well congestive heart failure is a
deficiency of a single vitam we've known
that since the
1700s and then there's cardiopathy heart
disease which causes sudden death in
athletes and people who do heavy
physical work people oh they just
dropped dead of a heart attack that's
cardiopathy heart disease is due to a
deficiency of a single minerals selenium
I've actually done 1,700 autopsies on K
age of 10 in kishan China they actually
died of that disease very familiar with
it and then of course there is coronary
thrombosis which is caused by an omega-3
essential fatty acid deficiency or ratio
problem between Omega-3s sixes and nines
and then there's obstructive artery
disease which is due to inflammatory
foods fried foods processed Meats oils
and gluten got to stay away from all the
bad stuff and of course you want to
protect yourself you take the 90
essential nutrients I like the healthy
heart and brain pack for this one 160
minerals 16 vitamins 12 essential amino
acids three essential fatty acids one
healthy heart and brain pack per 100
pounds of body weight I also like to
throw in the extra de-stress capsules
three of those twice a day per 100
pounds of body weight and you're home
free low libido in both males and
females is a big problem and this is due
to lack of nutrition 60 minerals 16
vitamins 12 essential amino acids three
essential fatty acids and of course we
need to keep the cardiovascular system
available and open we need to for both
males and females and we have to get the
hormones going so I like to have um six
eggs 68 eggs per 100 pounds of body
weight each day for both males and
females because testosterone estrogen
progesterone are all steroid hormones
95% of the weight of these hormones are
cholesterol you cannot be on a low
cholesterol diet you cannot be on a
cholesterol oring drugs and have a good
sex life um low tea and erectile
dysfunction menopause
is all due to a cholesterol deficiency a
physician inflicted problem okay I like
to come up with of course in the old
days we used to call it the stud hor
formula in the Philly pack today we have
what we call the healthy heart and brain
pack one per 100 pounds of body weight
it's going to give the testicles the
ovaries everything they need to make the
hormones they need to make in addition
to that for males I like to use the the
um selenium extra selenium I also like
to use extra PR FX and throw in GTO not
the car but get turned on great great
drink and then for females I like to use
the woman's FX 150y old herbal blend uh
called woman's FX the liquid form 1
ounce twice a day per 100 pounds of body
weight if they prefer capsules balance
FX three twice a day per 100 lounds of
body
weight get turned on
now what we shared with you today is the
way to add 25 to 50 healthful years to
your life you have to take the action to
make it happen this is something that is
doable there is over hundred billion
dollar worth of research involved in the
statements that have been given here
today only you though can make it happen
you have to take it and use it we can
save America together but we're going to
have to do it together because the
medical system has failed us terribly
only Dead Doctors Don't Lie
living younger longer is now a reality
thanks to youngevity
[Music]
here comes the
night once again